Hello! Everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Fury Survivor: Pixel Z.
It's a pixelated style Zombie Action Top-down Smashem...
game.
Is that Michael Jackson? Hi!
Given that I never played this game before, I have no idea how this is gonna go.
Uh-oh.
BRABRABRABRABRA BRABRABRA-
uh bRABRABRABRABRA
What are those?
I can't shoot those, alright, I'll whap you then.
Kadoodoosh.
Okay, c'mon.
Well, this seems like a nice-tempered game for tempered people.
Mild-mannered me playing this mild-mannered game full of mild-mannered Zomboes.
More like ZomBOZOS.
*weird laugh*
*that joke was ass*
I'm almost out of burgers.
BRABRABRABRABRABRABRA
frick.
BRABRABRABRA
Sorry lady.
Boom, take that box.
Boom, that's what you get for bullying Tiny Box TIm.
BRABRABRBABRABRABRA
Jeezums.
DUDUDUDU
Oh, you're ghost. I can't kill ghosts for some reason
It's against my
ethics.
DUDUDUDU
Uh oh, I've been froze.
BRABRABRABRABRABRARA
Your mistake was not killing me when you had the chance.
DUDUDUDU
AH OO UH EE UH
You think you can hit me?
Uh oh, shit. Oh, oh.
Ow. Ow.
That. That.
That-Okay that's- alright, there I go.
There was probably a way to get around those that I would have understood if I had known the game.
I'm going back to the Re-Foo-Chey (refuge)
As you may have picked up, I don't know how to play this game.
no you dont
You see all these wonderful glory-ness back at the base.
Um.
Well, is that?
I was gonna say "Is that Jesus?"
but that's Gabe Newell, isn't it?
I know Gabe Newell when I see him.
I know Gabe Newell when I see him!
Hello! How'ya doing?
Stop reaching for whatever you're reaching for.
Whatever this is...I don't know what this is!
And I'm not gonna lie and be like "I earned all of this."
because I did not earn all of this.
I'm gonna be straight up with you.
So,
this is not indicative to the experience
[???]
I've got-How much is that?
1 million coin(s).
And 1 5- 50,000
gold.
Which is wonderful and great
and I have a 100,000 arrows, y'know?
For huntin!
So thank you LT games for all the goodies and the special shinies and the good gear and all these accounts and all the high level and big damage and big number and
boom. Boom. Boom! BOOM!
And uh, thank you for sponsoring this video, but!
I am going to do the
honourable thing.
'Cause I am an
honourable man.
But!...
that's not the point.
So what I'm going to do
EiUEuiSSss
Okay, I've got a fresh version of the game so I'm gonna go into this
Eyes blind.
Eyes closed!
I'm not even going to use any of my six senses to be able to play this game.
So this is the beginning! Oo.
Good question.
I don't know m8
Mmm.
Probably.
[snorts] That's right.
Oh no...
oh.
It's not a stick, it's a bat!
It's a bat! Don't you know a bat when you see one?
Alright, okay.
eyayeehoheeyah hey
Oh no, is that a dog?!
I'll kill every one of you!
oh-Bob?
Bob!
B-Bob?
"Quick, run."? I don't kno-
OOHHOO
Alright.
ehhehheheh-
NYEH!
AHH!
Oh jeez, I'm not as whumpy as I was before.
There we go! Now that-
That's some satisfying whumpage!
Oh, yeah. (x2)
I'm not so sorry.
Uh, okay. Alright.
O-oh!
[mockingly] My God!
I give up!
I surrender!
Oh shit.
My wife!
Okay, you used to train in the Marine Corps?
You weren't a Marine?
You just went to the gym with other Marines? like...
What did you do?
I need to find my wife!
Alright, I gotta find my wife.
eeEH- BUH!
Did you hide my wife?
Alright, there we go. Got those.
Ah this is much better. See, this is what I like about starting games fresh
Because  this really does seem like a game
that I'm gonna love
Uh and I don't want to go into it being like,
"I earned all of these goodies,"  that I don't know how to use.
I r-
Wait, these don't explode, do they?
Let's find out!
Well, I mean they exploded but they didn't hurt me.
I'm gon' get'cha!
EH! EGH! EGH!
Oh. I guess a Skel-ling-ton (skeleton) shouldn't be-
You're gonna explode, ain't ya.
EGH! EGH! EGH!
Where's my wife?!
YOU HIDIN MY WIFE?
So things explode but apparently they don't hurt me.
Which is good!
'Cause I hurt myse-
BRUGH EGH!
GIVE ME MY WIFE.
WHERE'S MY WIFE?!
You got my-
No doggy no!
No...doggy no!
Oh doggy, no no!
No. no no!
Okay. Thank you. Thank you, doggy.
IS MY WIFE HIDING IN THIS TRUCK?
I'LL SAVE YA.
I'LL SAVE YOU, WIFE.
Oh, a coat
Oh, it does hurt me!
OH SHIT.
WEIGH WOAH
Man, I feel so bad!
I don't feel bad whomping the zomboe humans!
But the zombie puppies. Now that's-
That's where I draw the line. Okay.
Haboosh.
Perk?
"Unlock Perks at Level 5" What level am I?
Oh look at me...
I'm a handsome man!
[beautiful singing]
Ah, an electrical part that I got from that box.
I'm sure it still works.
Whumpus.
Whump.
Ooh!
I leveled up!
I leveled up, good. See, now I get the reward of leveling up!
And this got like some good feel to it, like honestly.
I love a good whump! And this game's got good whumpage!
Uh, yeah, very whumpy combat.
Like there's something very satisfying about-
Ugh.
Ew!
It's a-It's a swimming pool!
and it just got too crowded. It got so crowded that everybody died.
Oh good, this -
Eh, eh eh
Oh yeah,  just the factories have become the new age hell! Oh yeah, definitely, just the factories.
Not everything else!...
Look at the-Look at the trio!
Dougtrio, is that you?
Oh no! I'll save you.
Okay, alright. So that doesn't hurt me.
It's a lie!
Definitely didn't hurt me...
Oh.
Um..
Should I duck?
Dodge, dip, da-
Ooooooh...
[spluttering, laughter]
Okay, not the, not, uuuh -
Okay, it's a pattern, I think, it's gotta be a pattern, right?
Uh- mayb- uh I could dodge this with a little less narrowness.